you
hi everyone it's Jerry Aman chess calm
and just got paired up playing now a 3-2
game so let's see how this plays out ooh
Bishop g5 all right um I'm just gonna
develop if they want to take I got the
two bishops I'll be taking towards the
center okay I actually have some
experience with this structure usually
playing out of the caro-kann this knight
f6 move so yeah let's just move forward
and support my Center here I don't want
to be so quick to give up my exchange my
e pawn for this C pawn let's just play a
six if Queen b3 I have Queen d7 on any
ensuing Bishop b5 I have knight c6
however maybe I could consider Queen b6
here let me just consider for a moment
Queen b6 c5 Queen takes pawn takes a 6 B
497 I'm not quick enough to get my
Brooke off of the a file just yet but
that said maybe I can hmm I wonder maybe
after c5 just dropped back to c7 let's
see
Queen b6 supposed pawn takes maybe I
take the Queen yeah I'll do that yeah
let's try this okay I have to avoid the
Queen exchange I'll try to remember to
go back and explain why exactly if that
was too fast as to why taking the Queen
really isn't such a good idea
so I'm perfectly fine I consider my
LightSquared Bishop the expendable
Bishop and this move looks very ugly
because it makes him look like a super
bad piece and he is but I I want to stop
this is f4 break and I'll look to
circulate my knight into the weakness on
e4 maybe I could even consider this move
hmm yeah you know what I think I kind of
like that move
no it's not it's not necessary if Bishop
here I could do something like this not
sure where he belongs
I can maybe think about undermining hmm
let's see
and second thought maybe I should have
done something like this um let's do it
now and maybe challenge the knight
immediately if he plays into e5 97 yeah
let's challenge him I wonder if I should
have struck at this this pawn that's in
my position sooner if they're not
careful I could think about taking the
night and then rerouting my Bishop into
the square all right so let's recapture
and they're clearly stopping my idea of
the ship into f3 I'm not sure where my
bishop stands best let's go I'm going to
go here maintain some pressure on c5 I'm
not ruling out this idea of b6 I think
castling kingside will be fine even
though these guys are split they always
have to be a little bit careful if they
try an h3 g4 I have Bishop h4 in mind
and maybe isn't maybe now is the time to
try and open up the Queen side some or
let's do this first just so I have rook
g1 in mind in case something funny
happens with this I'm still going to
look to and to break open on this side
of the board fine with the two bishops
about I don't know how well I'm doing
with well hang on it's ready so I don't
know how well I'm doing with breaking
open the position but I think I'm given
an opportunity now to crack with c5 huh
as soon as this pawns no longer around
my king is vulnerable I'm beginning to
second-guess my decision to play King to
h8 so soon I think I should be alright
though
Bishop will be unprotected at the end on
this square threatening this advance
here creating a passed pawn so I finish
I'm pretty sure they have to take care
they have a passed pawn as well and
maybe I'm not so quick to take care yeah
I probably should as otherwise Bishop
here in pawn push okay hopefully there's
nothing bad happening against my bishop
right here okay just reroute I want to
get on f6 as soon as possible um
actually why should why is my picture up
for thinking about running let's get my
rook working he wasn't doing anything so
maybe that actually this is a threat
right now on a check I just play here I
shouldn't be bad actually what else was
I gonna do here what is the delay okay
I'd really like to still get this Bishop
working hmm I kind of want to play my
bishop into f6
you may do this I bet you that Bishop is
a little bit of a pest no yeah it stops
this pawn from moving maybe we're going
to have a queen trade okay
I guess here huh let's do this instead
to be careful of Knight here I have a
big-time ledge um yeah so much for that
Bishop being a past huh we're gonna have
one rook off I should probably get my
Bishop on this main diagonal as soon as
possible
hitting the night maybe Queen to a7 yes
the throat Queen a7 in there pressure on
the knight now and um could I take I
don't want to give that up so quick I
feel like I need to move if I was just
gonna keep pushing my life my
light-square bishop is not a happy piece
not at all yeah this Knight you know I
think I'm gonna need I think I need to
get rid of them that's a nothing move
just have to move fast
okay um
all right let's throw a pin in there I
don't know how good it is just gonna
have a queen exchange soon I'm very out
of play I think I need to keep the
Queen's on yeah because my King is just
way too far off from helping out
defending us this past pawn why am i pre
moving that it's not even a pre move
okay let's get back here I want to stop
the rook from pivoting on this square I
guess in the end I have to do this okay
here's a moment oh they're gonna have a
queen check that's a bad move on my part
but I might look out so have Queen takes
e3 on Knight takes bishop
so only not planned Queen c8 might work
okay at least I got my bishop working
let's just do this not sure why
different spot for my bishop I just want
to get my queen active not easy to do
just break this open a little bit I have
a passed pawn now maybe he could turn
into an animal actually it might work
might keep this dark square Bishop
around oh boy all right Queen takes pawn
ah that forces the Queen exchange eyed
Queen takes pawn there Queen takes c3
did I not have that fish up here let's
see if I could hold a draw how to take
here
there's no better well yeah cuz they are
Papon and they have the better Bishop
why are they doing that okay I just have
to sack my Bishop for the remaining pawn
okay there should be a draw throw my
King on d8 and all as well
um yeah let's just go back and forth
here can't ahead dislodge my king let's
actually avoid that because I would lose
the King and pawn ending okay they're
offering a drop I'll accept it obviously
I was too stressful I don't know where
my time went oh man before I look at it
with the before I look at it with the
computer let me yeah man I had one
window of opportunity there to take on
e3 but you know what III should have
done better I was referencing earlier
about Bishop to h5 and yeah I should I
should have played that before the
knight had the opportunity to pivot on
f3 and then sink into e5 yeah I should
have done that move I think it's a very
long game sixty-six moves as mentioned
important decision point here to go into
a queenless endgame or or not taking the
queen is just helpful to white and
because of this a file and what I was
trying to voice is the idea will be to
try and stop light from underling in
breaking at c6 with a b4 b5 but it just
won't be in time because I have many
things to do I have to play a six I have
to play my Knight to d7 and I have to
move my rook off of this file
unfortunately it's just not in time and
B five hits and white is doing very very
well this break basically translates
into a weakness on blacks Queen side so
and they won't it will not be a fun road
ahead for black at all so that's why in
other words I avoided the Queen exchange
just reload this and just get some
developing in f5 yeah I know this looks
very weird but another thing is that
this might be an idea just a triple op
suppose I do this and this move hits
this is just very ugly triple pawns and
maybe the rook starts to put pressure
one day so that's why I played f5 and I
should have been much much quicker to
play Bishop h5 here I think at least
we'll see what the computer suggesting
and I also wonder about b5 should I have
struck with b5 a bit sooner although I
for the moment it's covered enough with
the Queen on b3 in the pond yeah the
bishops I'm playing with the bishop pair
it did start to open up a little bit
here but not really enough to the point
where I could I think utilize their
strengths I mean it wasn't only until
much later that I was able to pivot just
for a moment on f3 but I think Y had
some a little tactic that they could
have used Queen to c8 and then maybe
picking up the Bishop although I had
Queen to e3 later on and it throwing his
check you know this is tricky I was
probably I was probably losing right
around here and then they had something
yeah I think it's important not to go I
need to keep the Queen's on the board
because this bishops just out of play my
king is just way too far away from
trying to help defend against the past
pawn and maybe the main reason is that
my king is maybe the safer of the two
probably right doesn't have such a good
home so maybe just from that for that
reason alone
keeping the Queen's on the board keep
this King off-balance the rooks were
exchanged and yeah I think maybe here
right there was this move check because
for the moment now there's no Knight
takes bishop because I should take the
Queen but I think Queen check here and
if this is still working out for me it's
only by luck Queen check there's Bishop
here and yeah I don't think that this is
working out this Knight is a fantastic
defender from for these like ensuing
checks square covered and such yeah this
this would have been very good Queen to
c8 but
didn't see that yeah they're putting a
lot of pressure on me on the clock and
this was my one moment this was my
moment
Queen check here and I'm gonna be
winning mm-hmm man what did I do
I just pushed okay
yeah well it was certainly messy they
were putting a lot of pressure on me on
the clock in position but uh let's
confirm it let's see what we could take
away with the help of stockfish okay
let's have a look here I was hesitant to
try and name this opening if you noticed
while playing I was forgetting if it was
the Trump offski or something else and
it is something else the Levitsky attack
the Trump house key is when Knight f6 is
played on move one by black and then the
bishop comes out like so but on d4 d5
and Bishop to g5 without the knight on
f6 this is the so-called Levitsky attack
so okay just develop Knight f6 we have
an immediate imbalance like for Bishop
exchange where are there some
fluctuations here with the evaluation
mean b6 c5 it does not like taking
Queens Queen c7 is suggested let me just
make certain it's not having a jump with
the evaluation but this is not fun to
play as black maybe it'll take some time
for the computer to recognize this but I
just know from experience if B 5 hits
it's just not going to be a very happy
day for black just the activity on the
Queen side it's not cool a 6
what's wrong with B for tonight.here
B five hits it's not fun
no no C takes bishop takes and you know
B 5 hit once and don't forget that it
may very well hit
you know just backing up why don't look
to still expand and break like this it's
a not fun so Queen c7 night there
mmm-hmm b6 I reference b6 but it's
pointing it out right away
I played Knight d7 and then my attention
was diverted some and rightly so because
of night h4 certainly don't want the
tripling up of my of pawns f4 it's
calling for a rook to b8 but yeah this
is the one thing I wanted to avoid this
type of pawn sacrifice yeah it's saying
it's favourable for for black but yeah I
didn't like this idea of you know look
at look at this dummy here
triple deaf pawns it's just not not cool
I guess I have some way to uh put some
pressure on the dark squares but I yeah
just want to avoid that altogether so
made him look really stupid and really
bad but I yeah I should be looking for
that b6 break much much sooner and this
is my moment to do so and that Knight f6
is - how might I describe this - hmm
maybe I'm being a bit too consumed with
the natural and in looking looking for
positional improvements when I should be
focused more on cracking at any white
pawns that are on dark squares any any
white pawns that on dark squares are
interfering with my unopposed dark
square bishop my x-factor bishop so I
should look to crack immediately with b6
C takes a takes and this is a much much
different game yeah much much different
game c5 will be hitting that well time
c5 I don't think that that can be
prevented I mean I have two minor pieces
upon in a queen that would be
facilitating this advance I do have to
take some care because I do we can be 5
but
with some preparation like Bishop d6
seems like quite a good square and then
castle and then look for that c5 break
mmm yeah b6 should have hit much sooner
when I did play b6 you know it only
happened after the Queen was out of the
pawns way so when I played b6 White was
in time to reinforce the c5 point with
b4 and I was never able to oh actually
that's not right I was ready so I was
never able to really rid white of their
c5 pawn that that that did happen in the
game but I should be much more Swift
with my attempt to open up the position
is what I'm getting at okay I'd have six
and actually let me back up for a moment
was it calling for yeah I had pointed
out maybe Bishop h5 you know many many
different moves could be played here I
should be I should be looking more
towards the bishop my dark square bishop
I need to crack with b6 much much sooner
yeah it's pretty even ish here even b6
now as what a pawn sacrifice takes takes
Queen takes is not a good idea okay well
I guess I'm gonna have some play here
I'm not a fan of really going in for
that c5 playing this down upon they have
two connectors mm-hmm I don't see myself
playing that I could see C playing that
after I have castled like right now I
would be considering it because at the
end I could immediately play to b8 and
then come back down and take b2 white
sense this right now and that's why they
got out of the way to prepare to meet b6
with b4 have this exchange in yeah I
don't know that it was necessary to give
up this point they captured right away
but they should probably leave it
sitting it's calling for a rook a to be
one you know just maintain this pawn
because he's really just biting on a
rock biting on a piece of granite that
particular line by the way this is this
videos being recorded
what is it October 18th and I actually
just learned not too long ago that of
the passing of a memory tape
International Master Emery Tate and
every every time I've used that phrase
before that abiding on a piece of
granite and I actually heard that line
from memory tape way back when when I
was like a teenager and playing in a
like a skittles room and in a tournament
the world open filly and unfortunately
he passed away so yeah very very sad
very very sad to learn of that like mic
line on chess calm wrote a very nice
tribute to him in an article maybe you
guys could check that out but I that
that particular phrase I remember him
saying that and always stuck out he
really brought the pieces to life he
would use that phrase I don't know it
was like you know what's this Bishop
doing is it's biting out a piece of
granite that's what he would say that's
what I recall at least and this is this
is essentially what the bishop is doing
here he's just biting on a rock for as
long as this pond here is reinforced
with these two ponds here it's uh you
know it's not going anywhere so biting
on a piece of granite granite as the
International master andry Tate would
say yeah it's a sad day for chests those
of you that do didn't know and we every
day or just if you're a fan of the game
really you didn't have to know him but
anyhow just wanted to point that out one
funny line interesting line to kind of
bring the game to life interesting
phrases and such yeah I got a little
distracted there but okay we have takes
takes
and their c5 yeah we did so we did see a
shift here as soon as c5 was given up
yeah after it takes so they should have
just kept that pawn on c5 so it's now
slightly better for black because I do
get the break in and he's liberated now
as a result he's a bit more free to
operate on different diagonals one that
points right towards the king one day
and it's already liking me here with d5
I think right around here I was
considering rook to rip to c8 yeah d5
striking further the dark squares hmm
another moment to crack at the the white
pawns in a much more timely fashion
mm-hmm okay I took what else was maybe
missed I ripped to a 3 instead of Bishop
to a3 okay eventually one pair of Brooks
comes off you know and then upon starts
to march I need to make certain I don't
exchange Queens here and one more yeah I
have to keep the Queens on the board
b5 oh you know right around this point I
wasn't even considering anything related
to pawn advances I was focused on my
Queen and rook and the possibilities
that my bishop had but as far as e5 this
is like a very very ugly move to play
just from a structural standpoint of
course you have to consider the concrete
lines but to exchange off this pawn for
early any pawn means that I now have
double isolated pawns and an isolated
pawn actually my whole structure if he's
not around you know it's just like this
or whatever she's everything is isolated
it's very unhealthy structure so I'm
just kind of shuffling here
in in in large part probably because of
the time but I had coin 2:8 between the
a5 came to d2 oh and that Bishop d1 yeah
sure I'm gonna see that okay
yeah it's really not so instructor from
here on out yeah and this is was this
was there missed opportunity for Queen
to c8 he's in it the Knights in a pin
but no longer in a pin and there goes my
bishop but that was missed and actually
this was missed here Queen takes c3 -
52:55 climbing it'll find mate soon I
imagine yep so many many misses for both
sides here is probably lucky once more
in this ending yeah
plus two for my opponent and yeah
another opportunity to take on e3 here
man
okay don't get too many a too many
opportunities do you and I wonder if
they could have done a little bit better
here I wouldn't have been so quick to
exchange these guys off I guess in the
end this is going to be a draw I mean
I'll be looking to just trade off both
my pawns for two of theirs and then sack
my Bishop for the remaining pawn but it
liquidated very quick into this type of
ending you just put your king on the
dark square and not be so quick to do
this exchange because you'd be losing I
think I was ready to do that in the game
but just keep the bishop on board and
yeah you're just not gonna kick the King
off of that square and we had a draw
from here but yeah anyway as usual feel
free to leave any feedback in the
comments section below to this video and
as usual I hope you got something out of
it that's all for now
take care bye